[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
of the morning's newspapers as they
arrive it's time to see what is making
headlines with the columnists and
broadcasters Steve Richards and the
former conservative special advisor
Salma Shah they'll be joining us from
now until just before midnight so let's
have a look at what is on some of those
front pages in the morning and we'll
start with the Metro Donald in the dock
is the headline covering that court
appearance of former president Trump in
New York
the financial times reports that uh
Trump entered a plea are not guilty to
those 34 charges and what the paper
describes as a day of drama
the guardian has a similar take while
also mentioning the judge's warning that
Trump must not say anything which in
Flames civil unrest
the star uses one of the former presence
made up words to describe the trouble
that he's in
while the I says that it's Mr Trump's
Day of Reckoning
in some other news The Daily Express
reports that Prince George has to take
on a major role in The King's coronation
next month
and the sun says that the title Queen
consort has been dropped from Queen
Camilla's name in the invitations for
the coronation
and to remind you that by scanning that
QR code that you see on your screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch along with us all right well
as I said we're joined tonight by the
columnist and broadcaster Steve riches
and the former conservative special
advisor Salma Shah Steve Salma good to
have you with us and good evening to you
both I mean one story in town on all the
front pages let's uh go through it in
order let's start with the front page of
the guardian and we'll start off with
you Stephen they've got the picture
there the one still image that we got
from that court in Manhattan As Trump
pleads not guilty those 34 felony
charges
yeah and the photo is of course
extraordinary because again you think of
this figure uh just a short time ago
president of the United States wielding
huge amounts of power uh commanding all
in front of him in the White House in
Washington and there he is in court
um and we have seen with the fall of
President Nixon with Watergate a drama
power
removed from a person at such speed it
was dramatic at the time but this in a
way is even more potent the
juxtaposition of memory you know Trump
in the white house and now Trump in
court and still of course some aspiring
presidential candidate
and somewhat I I presume you're watching
along uh um in 10 local the rest of it
and you will have seen the few sort of
fleeting images we got of Donald Trump
but it's not the Donald Trump that I
remember sort of the bombastic uh well
sort of aggressive in Donald Trump he
looks a bit chastened I don't know if
you agree
and I imagine that he's got strategists
and advisors choreographing exactly as
we've just heard from your
correspondence over in the states uh you
know exactly what he's going to do and
as Steve says this is not somebody who's
just a former president this is somebody
who is still in the race to gain the
Republican nomination in order to fight
against Joe Biden for the presidency
next year so all of this is actually
very carefully orchestrated and at the
arraignment the judges have been
concerned about the kind of rhetoric
that is going to be used and what kind
of messaging is going to be put out
there to potentially incite people to
Donald Trump's cause so it's going to be
interesting to see how this pans out but
there is very much that mine of how this
is going to play in to what happens in
the presidential nomination for the
Republicans well let's stick with that
thought summer we'll bring up the front
of the eye which is kind of exactly that
idea it's got a picture of trump just
before he walks into court the headline
on the front page of the eye tomorrow
morning is the Reckoning and that kind
of places this idea you know he is
running for president again
um he's ahead in the polls has raised
seven million pounds since he was
indicted but is this going to be sort of
the make or break moment for this guy
all the thing that I have found quite
interesting about
um what's happening is that his nearest
competitor is uh Rhonda Santos and he
seems to now be clear of him by a fair
few points in the polls
um on the Republican nomination so it's
not entirely and this is this is The
Madness of it it's not entirely clear
that being indicted for felonies is
something that is going to be negative
for Donald Trump in this race now and
Steve we're hearing earlier as well from
I think Michael wolf saying that in
Trump camp in mar-a-laga they're already
printing preparing to print the t-shirts
with his mug shot on
yeah
um and that side of it the political
side he remains in control he can decide
what he says at this rally later on he
can command support amongst his
Entourage his immediate Entourage and
his devotees in the United States but
what makes this more complicated is he's
not in charge of the legal process which
go at all kinds of different ways
um and so you have a aspiring candidate
who can arrange rallies who can frame
arguments that he is kind of a martyr
because of the Democrat establishment
out to get him all that's in his control
but the reason why it's interesting you
thought you looked a bit shaken in that
photo in the court and I I agree he is
partly bombastic and self-confident but
not holy
um that's our sense is you know there he
is sitting there in that Court not in
control
and so there are two parallel things
going on
um he will try and make the best of it
but how this legal process pans out is
not in his hands absolutely right and
that is interesting as well because I
don't know if you guys were watching
earlier when uh my colleague Mark Austin
was speaking to Anthony scaramucci
scaramucci made the point that Trump is
there on his own his family haven't been
there with him and uh sort of laying out
this idea that perhaps he might be
getting a little isolated at the moment
is he uh pushes forward with it with
another bid for the whites let's bring
up the front of the financial times
Stephen and I'll stick with you if we
can just to sort of stick with the legal
drama that we saw uh playing out today
and you will have seen following the um
the indictment being unsealed uh Alvin
Bragg reading out sort of the list of
charges and one thing that really struck
me when I heard all of that was that for
some of the um the the crimes that the
prosecutors said have been committed
Donald Trump's signature is on the
checks
yeah that's called evidence and um
all this is going to go
um but that's what makes this this legal
Dimension so complex and I heard your
interview with uh scaramucci and I I was
interested I mean Skyrim which is no
Trump fan these days but
um I was interested in his sense of a
figure who's becoming more politically
isolated but what is clear is it's
definitely him versus the court
um in the dynamic that's been played out
today in these 34 charges with we hear
more to come on other themes
um now you know there are some who say
and and we've heard it on Sky News
during the evening you know that this is
going to play to his advantage in the
short term but but I wonder whether in
the medium and long term it it that will
be the way it pans out yeah and someone
just have thought then from you um on
the sort of the the circus of all of
this I know if you as I said we're
watching it we saw the cars driving
along so the planes taking off the
planes taxing we're now waiting for him
to land we've got the flight tracker if
anyone wants to see that is the plane
makes his way to West Palm Beach as well
the Trump circus has rolled right back
into town hasn't it and we're going to
be sort of glued to this
um each and every time that uh this goes
back to court
yeah and it's not I mean obviously the
front pages of the papers are slightly
behind as you say the flight tracker has
like moved on slightly because it is
about the president former president
Trump going off to address this rally
but um not only is this a historic
occasion because it's the first time a
former president is facing criminal
charges severe criminal charges but it's
also because we are in many ways
addicted to the soap opera we've seen it
with some respects in this country with
Boris Johnson and we see it with you
know lots of um very charismatic if I
could put it that way uh leaders of
democratic societies and he's just
another example perhaps the best example
of how he sucks all the oxygen out of a
room uh when he's when he's in the media
Fray um so there's going to be so much
more of this for weeks months
there are uh the next court appearances
is sometime in December uh we think all
right we're waiting as we said 115 uh UK
times when Trump's going to be speaking
in West Palm Beach Salma Steve for now
thank you very much more from you later
but I just want to uh bring our viewers
the latest from Mr Trump as he's on that
plane on his way back to West Palm Beach
he's posted on his uh website truth
social and I'll read it out to you in
full you can see it's there Alvin Bragg
that's the da shuts down New York City
brought in 38 000 police officers and
will spend an estimated 200 million of
New York City funds for a totally legal
130 000
NDA on top of all of that the ninth
circuit courts just awarded me 122
000 over the 500 000 already awarded
from stormy horse face in quotation
marks Daniels
he goes on to say just lifted off for
Palm Beach we'll be delivering remarks
tonight at Mar-A-Lago at 8 15 Eastern
the hearing was shocking to many in that
they had no surprises and therefore no
case virtually every legal planet has
said that there is no case here that
there was nothing done illegally well
that is Donald Trump posting on true
social in the last few minutes uh laying
out his argument that uh he's done
nothing
illegal we'll see how that plays out we
have plenty more analysis on Donald's
Trump's appearance in that courtroom in
New York City in the past few hours and
of course have more coverage of what's
on the front page front pages and the
morning newspapers including this on the
front page of the Daily Star tomorrow
bigly trouble orange man baby makes
history tells us
[Music]
hello welcome back you're watching the
Press preview we're still with those of
the economists and broadcaster Steve
Richards and the former conservative
party special advisor Salma Salma Steve
let's just uh finish off on this segment
about Donald Trump's go to the front
page of the Daily Star which resurrects
one of Donald Trump's uh made it worse
one of my favorites from his time during
pres during his presidency uh the star
says that he's uh in a bigly trouble and
I guess uh some of this just kind of
just reiterates as well and sort of
reminds us as well sort of half articles
some of the some of Donald Trump's
tenure in the White House was
not just but also I think uh chapeau is
owed to the Red Top tabloids who can
actually give this into such succinct
way a description of what's going on
because I think they also above that big
headline uh refer to him as the uh
orange man baby delivery avoided that
bit
sort of make it appeal to a different
audience but you know Steve and I were
discussing in the Break
um how it's amazing how you know every
front porch that we're going to look at
for tomorrow is going with this story
yeah it really and as we're saying
before the break uh Steve though it
really is going to dominate our uh our
Collective uh attention for quite a
while isn't it
yeah it's quite unusual for every front
page to be dominated by this one per
story I think the last time it happened
in the UK was with the fall of trust
where you had the star joking about the
lettuce lasting longer and obviously the
kind of broad sheets focusing on it as
well here we have every paper from the
Star to the empty uh leading on it and
and we were sort of discussing is it
because his name still sells papers or
is it uh and I suspect It's a
combination of the two a real sense that
this is a historic moment when a very
recent president you know as I was
saying in the first half you know
exerting all the might of the presidency
albeit in his chaotic way now in court
we haven't had this before so it's a big
moment we most certainly have not all
right let's just move on then to the
other story and just challenging uh I do
this on leading on all the front pages
because the sun do have it on their
front page but it's not their lead story
their top story so you can see on the
front page of the sun here is a picture
of a
title on Coronation invitation before we
discuss this well guys I want to bring
you some uh breaking news that we've had
that Joe Biden has confirmed that his
wife Dr Jill Biden will be attending the
coronation uh representing the United
States so uh Simon let's just pick up on
then the front page of the Sun the new
Queen uh the title being used for the
first time officially
yes and obviously it's lovely to hear
that the president is sending such
senior representation uh to the
coronation
um but this this is a really interesting
story because it's uniquely British a
uniquely British Saga which is what was
going to happen to the Duchess of
Cornwall when uh King Charles has ceded
to the throne and uh you know she was
going to be known as Princess consort
there was Queen consult but now it is
official she will be known as Queen uh
and I think that is a testament to the
fact that this long journey we've all
been on with with her in the public eye
and the fact that people possibly are
quite ready to accept her as the queen
um so I think it's a it's an important
small but significant moment I think in
in British culture yeah and see if
you're not along to some of that and
someone's right it does feel like it's
been a long journey hasn't it but I
guess that it feels like it's kind of
fitting now and absolutely right
I'm nodding along out of politeness
because to be honest I haven't been
following the journey I just can't get
interested in these uh stories I know
everyone else is gripped by them um so I
was just kind of being polite what I do
find interesting Sam and I were here uh
I think on the eve of
um or certainly in the build up to the
Queen's funeral there was a lot of talk
about how
um an era was over the royal family
would struggle to adapt when such a
figure as the queen had died
um and yet here we are preparing for a
coronation and I think actually these
transitions can be made relatively
straightforwardly because there isn't
this sort of public pressure on these
people as there are with elected
politicians who are scrutinized in much
more depth and with much greater
hostility I know there are many storms
around the royal family and Harry and
all the rest of it but but honestly
compared with what elected politicians
get they that they do okay
all right Steve someone Stephen I won't
be asking what you're doing on the 6th
of mays I think I know what the answer
to that will be all right Steve so I
really appreciate your time we'll have
more from you later on